pixar's lightyear is experiencing some
turbulence at the box office
it did not go as planned the mission was
unsuccessful
first announced in 2020 during disney
investor day the toy story spin-off
seemed to be on track to be another win
for the studio behind ratatouille and
wally the character of buzz lightyear
then voiced by tim allen first appeared
in toy story pixar's debut feature film
while the toy story series spawned
several successful sequels the character
of buzz lightyear himself would go on to
headline his own direct to video
spin-off movie and even an animated
series called buzz lightyear of star
command that ran for over 60 episodes
more than proving the character's
popularity seeing as the toy story
franchise has grossed over 3 billion
dollars worldwide and has already
successfully spawned other buzz
lightyear spin-offs it may come as a
surprise that light year has been far
from a success variety reports that the
film cost 200 million dollars to produce
and that doesn't even account for the
marketing budget the movie opened to a
disappointingly low 51 million dollar
box office a far cry from the 121
million dollar opening haul of toy story
4. on the critical front the film holds
a 76 on rotten tomatoes that is far from
a flop review-wise but it does make it
the lowest rated film in the franchise
a flurry of confusion and indifference
began to pile up shortly before the
film's release coupled with an
unfortunate release date and a lack of
distinct identity lightyear serves as a
cautionary tale for disney that
audiences won't just show up for
anything pixar me i'm gonna get played
with
see ya
prospective audiences were left
scratching their heads when lightyear
was announced in 2020. captain america
star chris evans was brought on board to
voice the titular character replacing
tim allen who had been playing the space
ranger in the toy story series since
1995. evan's casting announcement caused
significant confusion which seemingly
led to the actor issuing a tweet that
stated this is the origin story of the
human buzz lightyear that the toy is
based on hey guys look it's the real
buzz lightyear however when audiences
set down to watch the film they were
greeted with on-screen text that
revealed that lightyear is actually the
film that andy the owner of the buzz
lightyear action figure from toy story
saw in 1995 confused so were we it
certainly didn't help that the film's
marketing campaign failed to convey the
tone of light year while pixar has
always been a studio that has created
films for children and young adults
they're largely beloved by viewers of
all ages lightyear on the other hand
appeared to be a film mostly dedicated
to the older crowd the film's initial
teaser relied heavily on david bowie's
star man and pitched itself as a
throwback space opera inspired by the
films of the 80s a direction that
implied it was tugging on the nostalgia
of those who remember the decade some
speculated that the film would be
pixar's first pg-13 project which didn't
end up being the case however the notion
that it could have been alongside the
film's confusing premise and hit and
miss marketing certainly alienated
viewers during opening weekend
especially with more interesting
projects in theaters
oh no
the premise of light year may have been
confusing but pixar's name still holds
weight which seemingly poised the film
to deliver the box office goods perhaps
that would have happened if the toy
story spin-off opened earlier this year
light year hit theaters on june 17th
father's day weekend while that slot may
have been strategic for pixar and disney
when the animated project was announced
in 2020 the studios clearly
underestimated their competition light
year opened a week after jurassic world
dominion the long-awaited finale to the
jurassic saga deadline reports that the
dinosaur bonanza raked in 58.6 million
dollars on father's day weekend trumping
the 51 million dollar debut of light
year the film also faced fierce
competition from top gun maverick which
brought in a whopping 44 million dollars
making it the second highest fourth
weekend haul since avatar both dominion
and maverick cater far more to the
father's day crowd than light year while
dominion was riddled with issues the
jurassic world franchise will always
have a hold over general audiences then
there is the continued runaway success
of maverick the sequel to the 1986 hit
has become a cultural phenomenon
prompting repeat viewings from some
audience members the tom cruise-led
sequel is far more dad-centric than
lightyear it is a bigger draw for those
looking for nostalgia and its poignant
story and jaw-dropping action sequences
appeal more to the grown-up crowd in
fact audiences over 35 have been showing
up in droves to see maverick's sophomore
outing while the character of buzz
lightyear certainly holds his own weight
in terms of nostalgia the pixar animated
epic just doesn't seem to have been the
right choice for father's day weekend
taking a look at pixar's recent slate of
films light year notably stands out as
the sole ipcentric project since 2019's
toy story 4. pixar's last proper
theatrical release was onward which
underperformed due to the impact of the
coven 19 pandemic in 2020. during the
pandemic disney sent soul luca and
turning red straight to disney plus much
to the chagrin of pixar employees each
of those three original films received
near unanimous acclaim they all boast a
rotten tomato score of over 90
and have become pop culture phenomenons
in their own right it speaks volumes
that disney sent some of pixar's most
interesting films in recent memory
ostensibly direct to video diluting the
brand which is mostly synonymous with
quality if modern audiences associate
pixar with disney plus they'll be
hard-pressed to spend the time heading
to the theaters when they know lightyear
will be on the service sooner rather
than later to that end amidst the
confusion viewers seem more interested
in pixar's original stories films like
turning red have sparked cultural
conversations echoing the impact of the
studio's earlier projects like inside
out and ratatouille on the other hand
the conversations around light year have
largely focused on the fact that as
david sims wrote in his review for the
atlantic hollywood is so lost in the
rabbit holes of its own intellectual
property that it's cooking up origin
stories for fictional toys despite
focusing on a beloved character
lightyear failed to launch the moment
pixar and disney just assumed audiences
would show up for a toy story spin-off
it turns out to get people out to the
theaters these days you need to give
them something more check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
and tv shows are coming soon subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
you